so I just got back from watching
Oppenheimer that's right a few days
before Barbie Heimer erupts around the
world is it called Barbie Heimer Rob and
Barbie I don't know it's one of the two
anyway you got Barbie
you know a movie about
plastic dolls
you know you got Margot Robbie Ryan
Gosling the women are going nuts for him
and Barbie dolls and then you got
Oppenheimer the father of the atomic
bomb very serious very dramatic film
two Polar Opposites
I saw Oppenheimer
and this morning I saw it at 10 A.M in
the morning had my coffee I'm sitting in
the movie I'm watching it within five
minutes I'm like
wow this is a beautiful film acting the
sound the visuals are just stunning I
mean Christopher Nolan is firing on all
cylinders I'm like oh yeah we got
ourselves an Academy Award winner right
here if this movie doesn't win well
there may be a reason for it I'll talk
about that in just a bit but he's gonna
get nominated best directing for sure
best picture for sure Cillian Murphy is
gonna win best actor unless some actor
comes out playing some majorly
handicapped character because you know
how the academy likes those kind of
rules you know if you're playing a
handicapped person you can probably
gonna win if someone doesn't do that
this year
he's got the Academy Award
brilliant performance magnetic the way
that he worked in just just oh showcase
the various different aspects of J
Robert oppenheimer's personality I mean
Cillian Murphy was just awesome
everybody in this movie is fantastic
everyone and this movie is like the
Avengers of Hollywood they all got in
this movie Christopher Nolan could call
up Marlon Brando say can he get out of
the grave and come into my movie Marlon
will say yes I'll be there that's what
this movie's like Marlon's it not in it
by the way I'm just saying but I mean
you're seeing actors we haven't seen in
years Josh Hartnett is in the movie he's
great Casey Affleck we haven't seen him
in a bit he's great there's so many
amazing actors half the time I'm
watching this movie I'm like who's
showing up next wow you're really good
this is amazing Matt Damon probably
will get nominated for best supporting
actor Robert Downey Jr will get
nominated for best supporting actor he's
freaking phenomenal in this yeah Iron
Man is back playing a very different
character and it just goes to show you
how talented the man is he's just
freaking amazing everyone is great and
you know what they did do you know how
good this movie is they made Emily Blunt
look average average the makeup is that
good in this movie how do you make Emily
Blunt look ma average I don't know how
you do it but Christopher Nolan did and
I'm shocked plus she's a fantastic
actress by the way okay she's phenomenal
as Kitty is as J Robert oppenheimer's
wife on point I mean
wow we'll get nominated as well so I'm
watching the film I'm liking where it's
going it kind of goes black and white in
color at times you're like I think I
know why the black and white comes into
play sort of these more nefarious more
these secret meetings things but then
it changes and it's like okay it's not
going back in time and it's not that
it's something else I don't know it just
it's sporadic you just go with it and
it's kind of cool
half the time the shots are not in Focus
I'm like did you get it like a new DP
because they're close up on the people's
faces and the blur I don't know it's
something you'll notice in the movie
because everything is like massively
close up on everybody I mean it's IMAX
and so you see them in like 60 feet high
and you're like the shot's not in Focus
but anyway it is what it is
then I'm like okay I'm going through his
history as a young student he becomes a
professor he's studying quantum
mechanics or quantum physics or one of
these things he's going through this he
meets he knows Einstein he's going you
know gets recruited by the US government
to take over this Manhattan Project but
before that he was a very liberal
Professor who was dabbling with
Communism at the time and you know it
gets into all these little these
Essences and these little you know small
pockets of U.S history which are
fascinating if you're an American but if
you're not well
good luck because Christopher Nolan
expects you to have read or know about
Oppenheimer before you go to this movie
because if you don't good luck there's
barely an explanation for this thing
nothing there's no timestamp there's no
text on the screen to say 1932 1945
nothing you either know by how old
Cillian Murphy looks in the scene
or you don't that's how I gauged it to
be honest with you because I was like
where are we at right now oh he looks
younger okay so he's longer hair he's a
student oh he's shorter hair gray hair
okay we're now in modern times that's
the only way you know about this movie
Christopher Nolan expects you to watch
this movie every second of this film and
if you don't you have to go to the
bathroom well good luck bye bye there
goes three hours I'm joking it's not
that bad but he could be a little bit
more explanatory in this film and that's
one of the issues with this film and the
other issue to this film
the other issue
I'll tell you right after this sponsor
message here at geek culture we've
tested plenty of chairs but Secret Life
gaming chairs remain one of our
favorites whether it's for work or play
they feel great to lean back against
with the ergonomic features offering
support for the whole body from the head
and back to the arms and even something
for your butt this mix of format
function helps the Titan Evo 2020 to
deliver the best seating experience like
no other for more information check out
secretlab.co the other issue to this
movie is it is way too long
it is at least a half hour too long
look three hours is a lot to sit through
on a film I mean the longest film before
this one was Avatar the sequel to it
right but that was you know visually
stimulating with 3D and action and all
these things
this movie primarily is
Talking Heads and they're really close
up like massively close up but you do
get a sex scene in this film Christopher
Nolan brought back the sex scene to
cinema oh be damn it's been how many
years since I've seen one of those but
he brought it back Florence Pugh Celine
Murphy it was a hot scene I got to tell
you she's a beautiful woman and she's a
fantastic actress it was done very
Tastefully but there's a sex scene
actually there's two
there you go Christopher Nolan thank you
but besides that I mean this film is
long man and you know by the time you
see the testing of the atomic bomb we
are now into the second hour of this
film that's how long it is I thought to
myself you know I was watching the movie
for a while I'm like okay we're probably
cleared two hours already I looked at my
watch an hour and 15 minutes I'm like
oh I gotta keep going with this okay I
went to the bathroom twice in this thing
but as soon as the credits rolled I was
out of there fast man I could not wait
to get out because I gotta get on my day
and I get that this movie wants to
explain a lot of things in history I
understand that but there were a lot of
scenes that felt very repetitive and I
think it would have been nice if someone
watched this film with Christopher Nolan
and said Chris
brilliant job directing brilliant job
acting great visuals but you gotta cut a
little bit out of this move it's not
like The Godfather where every scene is
important there are a lot of scenes as I
mentioned were repetitive and a lot of
scenes didn't need to be there to push
the story forward they just were there
just to Showcase some great writing it
kind of felt a little self-indulgent at
times but yeah man if you cut 20 30
minutes out of this movie it's a perfect
movie The acting the visuals the makeup
the sound the music it is just
phenomenal
but it's too long anyway
those are my thoughts on Oppenheimer let
me know your thoughts in the comment
section below did you agree with me
after watching this movie or do you have
a different opinion I would love to hear
from you and if you like my movie
reviews check out more of them right
here